foreign
people here will probably be seeing the
news filtering through and I don't think
we can start this session without
acknowledging that there has been a
serious incident in Nottingham this
morning information is still coming
through but
um it's just been reported that three
people have lost their lives so I'm sure
I speak for everybody in this room in
saying that we'd like to just send our
thoughts to all those affected and the
Emergency Services who are responding to
this as we speak what are your thoughts
this morning
a shock I think like everybody else to
shop that was knotting is just a
wonderful City and it's you know it's
always got a great Vibe about it you
always feel really safe on the streets
and yeah we just it's just foreign tours
in in all sorts of ways really and just
conscious that people like Cherie are
going to be really unsettled by this
um and the police are you know for them
you know these sort of things are
planned they know how to respond
um it would have been a surprise but not
a surprise in as much as they will have
rehearsed all of that sort of you know
dealing with that
Bradford Dreadful tragedy because you
have multiple locations and
investigations ongoing it spreads the
number of people that have been drawn
into this yeah absolutely and just you
know people waking up this morning
and just not being able to get to work
and why and then like Cherie they find
out and
you know are my children safe and you
know where are they and where are people
that I loved that were going out last
night or early early hours of this
morning where are they are they safe
they'll be all of that going on
foreign